well I think what you're implying is
we're designed to defend small tribal
groups of people in the unmanned
gathering situation and we're crowded
into cities by the millions and does
this increase violence and the answer is
it's a contributing factor but I
encountered an old friend recently and I
asked him what have you been doing and
he said I founded something called the
Rocky Mountain Center for the Study of
media violence and he explained to me
something that I have never understood
because you always hear that violence in
media is used to sell things but none of
us are violent people we're all turned
off by violence so how does violence use
to sell things he said well how it works
is in the evening news which is where
all the ad revenue is made because
that's where most local stations are
most watched the most violent disgusting
and value denying and mint denigrating
story is pushed right before the main
commercial break and so your desire to
get away from this horrible information
is satisfied when the cut is to the
product and there is an unconscious
blood of relief associated with the
product
we are being manipulated we have created
social institutions such as consumer
capitalism that are so unfriendly to our
innate human asst that they are actually
redesigning us these social systems to
be more brutal less caring more
acquisitive more fetishistic than we
naturally would be and again the
antidote to this is awareness of your
immediate environment and the trips that
are being run on you and the ways in
which we are being manipulated man is
not bad humanity is not flawed what is
flawed are ideologies and social systems
that distort humaneness for purposes
usually of commerce or conquest and
until you figure out that this is going
on we're all going to be run like rats
through a maze culture is an
intelligence test and when you pass that
test you don't give a [ __ ] about culture